Deutschland hat ein großes Problem es
fehlen schon heute Lehrer massenhaft
in Zukunft sollen es sogar 2070 oder gar
hunderttausend sein wie sollen Lehrer da
guten Unterricht machen
wir können nicht mehr wir können es so
in dieser Art auch wenn wir wollen uns
aufarbeiten nicht mehr beschulen und
auch regelmäßiger Unterricht nicht mehr
selbstverständlich in der Schule habe
ich zwei Stunden entfallen und das ist
nervig
dabei arbeiten die Lehrer bereits am
Limit man kann den Lehrern nicht noch
zu Pädagogen schütteln schon lange den
Kopf
die Welt kommen und man weiß auch dass
jemand in die Schule gehen
warum gibt es nicht genügend Lehrer an
unseren Schulen
wir sind in Bergisch Gladbach an einer
Realschule
jeden Tag der gespannte Blick der
Schüler auf den Vertretungsplan
so wir können ja aber
wird es heute regulären Unterricht geben
für die neuen B und C findet der
Matheunterricht statt allerdings
gemeinsam als Vertretungsstunde wir
treffen den Direktor Martin Havers er
wird die beiden neunten Klassen
unterrichten der Schulleiter muss selbst
dran denn sie sind zu wenig Lehrer an
der Schule und morgen
zwei Klassen gleichzeitig das heißt
doppelt so viele Schüler eine
Herausforderung nicht alle haben Bock
auf Mathe nicht alle sind auf dem
gleichen Wissensstand
habe ich da die unterschiedlichen Zahlen
eingesetzt der Schulleiter lässt die
Klasse in Gruppen arbeiten
und das nicht so sind alle mit dem Stoff
beschäftigt
und er kann kontrollieren ob sie die
Aufgaben verstanden haben lange schon
sind an der Schule zwei Stellen
unbesetzt diese beiden Klassen leiden
besonders darunter
fünf wechselnde Lehrer schon gehabt
jetzt von der achten bis zur 9 und das
ist halt ein bisschen
nervig bin dann irgendwann nicht mehr
mitgekommen richtig ich habe dann auch
richtig keine Aufgaben mehr verstanden
dachte mir ihr habt im Unterricht auch
gar nichts mehr gemacht und dachte mir
so mache ich später mit meinem Vater und
so das ist schon sehr viel Druck weil
man muss sich das ja dann irgendwie dann
doch selber beibringen oder mal die
Eltern fragen oder einfach mal gucken
Nachhilfe oder so
es hat sich gerade noch eine Kollegin
krank gemeldet okay
solche Hiobsbotschaften gehören schon
lange zum Job von Thomas Redmann der
Konrektor schreibt die Vertretungspläne
Ziel ist möglichst viel Unterricht
stattfinden zu lassen ist ja ganz klar
ist aber nicht möglich und umso
schwieriger fällt es mir auch eben
persönlich wenn ich dann entscheiden
muss okay heute bleibt die 7b zu Hause
war gestern der Fall ist für alle Eltern
unzufriedenstellend für mich auch und
ich hadere immer oder ich zögere immer
auch ob ich wirklich diese Entscheidung
treffen soll aber manchmal lässt es sich
nicht ändern von den 24 Lehrern der
Schule arbeiten sieben in Teilzeit
selten ist das Kollegium komplett
täglich fehlen drei bis vier Kollegen
wegen Krankheit oder Klassenfahrt
Reserven für diese Ausfälle gibt es
schon jetzt nicht die ständigen
Verschiebungen bringen die Lehrpläne
aller durcheinander die ganzen
langfristigen Planung der Kollegen
Unterrichts rein werden gestört wenn ich
denen eine Stunde nehme es hängt Klausur
dran wir haben straffen Plan wann
Klausuren geschrieben werden können weil
Kurse und Hauptfächer im Wechsel sind es
gibt eine bestimmte Zeiträume und dann
fallen die Kollegen an zu schwimmen es
erhöhte Stresslevel und ist nicht gerade
gesundheitsförderlich es muss man
einfach so sagen Freistunden sind selten
kaum können Sie mal durchatmen oder
schnell doch etwas vorbereiten
Vertretungsstunden gehören zum Alltag
und sind Stress in der ersten Stunde
muss ich eine Kollegin vertreten die
krankheitsbedingt leider nicht kommen
konnte und hatte dann eine sogenannte
doppelaufsicht das bedeutet ich habe
zwei Klassen gleichzeitig betreut ja wo
das Unterricht natürlich schwieriger
fällt eine fünf eine Klasse 10 die Firma
möchte ich auch nicht komplett alleine
lassen auch wenn die Klassenräume jetzt
gegenüberliegen aber natürlich kann ich
dann den Unterrichtsstoff nicht so
vermitteln wie das dann eigentlich
machen würde und mir gewünscht hätte da
bleibt oft nur die Kinder irgendwie
beschäftigen mit Aufgaben und Übungen
neuer Stoff kann so nicht vermittelt
werden
die Situation ist für alle im Kollegium
unbefriedigend die Frage an euch wie
würdet ihr diese Strecke
bezeichnen wollen
der Schulleiter Martin Havers sucht
händeringend Lehrer die Stellen sind
längst genehmigt auch das Geld um sie zu
bezahlen ist da doch es gibt kaum
Bewerber
[Musik]
wir haben zwei Stellen ausgeschrieben im
Februar eine einzige Bewerberin die hat
sich aber auch noch an vielen anderen
Schulen beworben wir hatten das Glück
Sie einstellen zu dürfen im Februar die
zweite Stelle haben wir nicht besetzt
bekommen und jetzt zum ersten Mai die
Bewerbungen sind eingegangen wir haben
einen einzigen Bewerber nicht nur hier
fehlen Lehrer bundesweit ist der Mangel
dramatisch
12.000 Lehrer fehlen aktuell sagen die
Kultusminister der Verband Bildung und
Erziehung kommt sogar auf 50.000 offene
Stellen
[Musik]
besonders groß ist der Mangel an
Deutschlands Grundschulen Bayern lange
selbst ernannter bildungsmuster Schüler
Lehrermangel auch hier gleichzeitig
wachsen die Anforderungen und Aufgaben
für Lehrkräfte wir besuchen die
Friedrich rückert-grundschule erste
Stunde Englischunterricht in der 4b
21 Kinder lernen mit Rektorin Sabrina
neckow
Ski
vier Schüler haben deutsche Wurzeln der
Rest kommt aus vielen Teilen der Welt
Russland USA Mazedonien Syrien oder Irak
Multikulti im Klassenzimmer wir haben
eine Migrationsanteil von weit über 90
Prozent der geht eher auf hundert
Prozent und haben zudem auch Kinder die
sonderpädagogischen Förderbedarf haben
auch im Rahmen von ungefähr 20%
sicherlich ist diese Schule besonders
sie zeigt uns jedoch überall haben
Lehrkräfte mehr Aufgaben als nur Wissen
zu vermitteln sie sind Erzieher
Psychologen und Sozialarbeiter
wir haben drei Kinder die einfach so
laufen und der Rest braucht Hilfe und
wir haben in fast allen Klassen
mindestens drei bis fünf Kinder die kein
einziges Wort Deutsch sprechen und das
macht das Unterrichten für uns wirklich
jeden Tag zu einer kraftaufgabe
dazu noch die Nachricht der Konrektorin
Tanja Kerz an diesem Morgen von 20
Lehrkräften sind vier krank 70 Wochen
Unterrichtsstunden fallen somit aus mehr
Arbeit für alle anderen wieso oft
ich muss jede Woche Kollegen fragen
Mensch könntest du eine halbe Stunde
länger bleiben könntest du ein bisschen
Hofpause noch übernehmen da fehlt eine
Lehrkraft und ich sehe es an den
Kollegen ich kann nicht mehr Mangel als
Dauerzustand darunter leidet der
Unterricht leiden die Kinder und die
Lehrkräfte es kann nicht immer nur auf
den Schultern derer ausgetragen werden
die hier noch durchhalten ja wenn man da
immer noch Additiv immer noch eine Sache
oben drauf setzen oben drauf setzen dann
machen wir die die hier so resilien
durchhalten auch noch schlafen und dann
kollabiert das System absolut weil wir
sprechen hier von wir sprechen hier von
Bildungsqualität
doch wie soll das gehen mit
Schulpsychologen und Sozialarbeitern
stundenweise und nur einer
Förderlehrerin für 230 Kinder
ist das ein Igel
Förderlehrerin Chiara Sasso unterstützt
Erstklässler wie die sechsjährige Fatma
aus Syrien die noch Probleme beim
Rechnen und Schreiben hat
jedes Wort ein kleiner Erfolg doch sechs
Kindern in einer Dreiviertelstunde
gerecht zu werden ihre Defizite
auszugleichen sie zu motivieren sei kaum
zu schaffen sagt die 25-Jährige
das sieht ja ich bin hier die ganze Zeit
am rot werden und jeder sagt was hast du
Frau Sasso und das ist jetzt hier auch
wenn es nur sechs Kinder sind die
Herausforderung immer mehr
Herausforderungen immer weniger
Lehrkräfte das sei nicht mehr zu stemmen
allein gelassen fühle ich mich von der
Politik ja weil weil die Problematik das
Lehrermangels ja schon sehr lange
bekannt ist das ist ja nicht so dass wir
hier jetzt sind viele Kinder da aber es
fehlen Lehrer und der Blick in die
Zukunft ist noch düsterer die Zahlen für
die Prognosen sind je nach Sichtweise
dramatisch im Jahr 2035 fehlen laut
Kultusminister
24.000 Lehrer von fast 76.000 geht das
Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft aus
mit weit über 85.000 fehlenden
Lehrkräften rechnet Professor Klaus
Klemm
die Prognosen des bildungsforschers sind
viel höher weil er mehr Daten
berücksichtigt er rechnet nicht nur mit
Geburtenraten Klassengrößen oder
künftigen Pensionierungen sondern auch
mit dem Zusatzbedarf etwa für
Ganztagsschulen Inklusion und
Integration die Berechnungen der
Kultusminister hält er für falsch also
die Kulissen der Konferenz selbst die
haben Spezialisten die können mit Excel
arbeiten und 16 Daten zusammenziehen
aber mehr macht die
Kultusministerkonferenz nicht und die
haben einfach die aktuellen Zahlen
konstant fortgeschrieben das hochgradig
unterrührt und führt dazu zu niedrigen
Zahlen selbst wenn es nur 24.000
fehlende Lehrer werden ist das eine
Masse es sind viel viel mehr die
Kultusminister kennen seine Zahlen
bleiben aber bei ihren Berechnungen
dabei wird das Problem immer größer laut
Schätzungen wird die Zahl der Schüler um
9% in den kommenden zehn Jahren steigen
die Zahl der Lehramts Absolventen aber
es zuletzt rapide gesunken um 13,9%
. die Stellen sind da am Geld liegt es
nicht aber warum gibt es kaum
nachwuchslehrer
an der Grundschule im bayerischen Donau
bei Regensburg kämpfen sie um jede
Lehrkraft eine Stelle ist unbesetzt zwei
Lehrer krank Löcher im Unterricht werden
mit mobilen reservekräften gestopft noch
geht es irgendwie aber was den Nachwuchs
angeht sieht Petra Falter Direktorin der
Schule schwarz
wenn ich in die Zukunft schaue
ja sehe ich schon möglicherweise dunkle
Wolken aufziehen wie es mit der
zukünftigen Versorgung aussieht
Unterricht in der 4b mit Lehrerin Maria
Heil mit dabei 27 und Jakob Schmidt die
beiden 20-Jährigen studieren Lehramt
Grundschule ihr erster Eindruck mit der
Theorie an der Uni hat der Schulalltag
nur wenig zu tun
und da wäre wahrscheinlich mehr solcher
Praktika interessant für jeden der im
Grundschule oder Mittelschule studiert
denn sie erleben auch die
Herausforderungen und Belastungen im
Klassenzimmer ganz direkt doch der Staat
macht es den jungen Leuten schwer hohe
Zulassungsbeschränkungen ähnlich der für
Medizin
hohe Anforderungen im Studium mit zu
umfangreichen Studieninhalten schrecken
viele ab im Hauptwort zum Beispiel so
ein bisschen überqualifiziert in meiner
Meinung nach weil wir halt extrem viel
Sachen machen die in der Grundschule vom
Stoff einfach nicht benötigt werden
die Folge manche brechen ab steigen aus
wechseln in ein anderes Fach
also ich persönlich kenne schon welche
die nach dem ersten oder zweiten
Semester sagen ja sie machen das nicht
weiter weil durchaus die ein oder andere
Prüfung vielleicht eben zu habe ich es
ist würde ich aber sagen wir machen
erstmal die umstellprobe
Grundschullehrerin Maria Heil ist 33 ihr
Studium liegt noch nicht so lange zurück
doch viel habe sich in den letzten
Jahren in den Schulen verändert
die Kinder bringen ganz unterschiedliche
Voraussetzungen mit von der
Muttersprache bis hin zu ja den eigenen
psychischen Voraussetzungen die
Bedürfnisse der Kinder sind sehr
vielfältig man merkt auch einfach dass
die Anforderungen gestiegen sind
Schule hat sich gewandelt ganz klar aber
auch das Studium
jeder hat doch die Chance zu gewinnen
die Ausbildung müsste angepasst werden
an die Bedürfnisse sagt Rektorin Petra
Vater
ich finde das ist einfach ab Pflicht für
für ein Land und für ein Staat da
wirklich auch gute Voraussetzungen und
zu bieten wir sind kein Land mit vielen
Rohstoffen unser Potenzial ist die
Bildung und das sollte man wirklich
geben was zu geben ist zu tun
es gibt zu wenig Lehrer zu wenig
Bewerber für offene Stellen und kaum
Nachwuchs was tun
der Beruf müsste dringend attraktiver
werden aber das Gegenteil passiert
gerade in ihrer Not haben die
Kultusminister kürzlich Wissenschaftler
beauftragt schnelle Lösungen zu
erarbeiten der Erziehungswissenschaftler
Professor Olaf Köller hat mit seinem
Team bei den bereits vorhandenen
Lehrerinnen und Lehrern noch Potenzial
entdeckt
die Frage ist ob man bereit ist kleinere
Opfer zu bringen Stichwort ein oder zwei
Stunden pro Woche mehr um diesen
Schülerinnen und Schülern Gutes zu tun
denn eins bleibt ja auch bestehen
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer wie alle Beamten
in Deutschland haben unheimliche
Privilegien und das sind die Vorschläge
der Expertenkommission Lehrer sollen
mehr arbeiten sie sollen später in
Pension gehen Pensionäre sollen zurück
in den Beruf es soll weniger Teilzeit
geben dazu sollen mehr Quereinsteiger an
Schulen unterrichten und gegen den
Stress sollen Yoga und Atemübungen
helfen
doch schafft man damit Anreize für den
Lehrer Beruf
unpopuläre Vorschläge das weiß auch der
Wissenschaftler die nur kurzfristig
helfen können wir wünschen uns natürlich
auf Dauer dass das System in der Lage
ist Modelle zu finden um auch wieder
mehr qualifizierte Lehrkräfte in die
Schulen zu bringen das muss man einfach
sagen ja die Politik über Jahrzehnte die
Augen verschlossen vor demografischen
Entwicklung und hat uns in eine
Situation gebracht in der nicht nur
Schule nicht funktioniert sondern das
ganze System nicht mehr funktioniert
in Bayern haben sie ähnliche
Notmaßnahmen vor drei Jahren bereits
eingeführt ein ganzes Bündel an
Maßnahmen zur Sicherstellung der
Unterrichtsversorgung wurde erlassen
unterm Strich bedeutet das für die
Lehrkräfte mehr Unterrichtsstunden
Pension erst mit 65 weniger arbeiten in
Teilzeit wie reagiert die Lehrerschaft
darauf in der Schweinfurter Grundschule
herrscht größtenteils Unverständnis man
kann den Lehrer nicht noch mehr
zu und ich finde
ich bin jetzt 43 Jahre in dem Geschäft
und ich denke
es ist nicht mein Problem dass die
verpasst haben rechtzeitig dem
Lehrermangel entgegen zu werden
ich Power so wie ich kann und ich
arbeite so wie ich kann aber irgendwann
ist es auch mal gut bringt was wenn wir
sagen okay wir machen es nicht
es geht ja wieder oft auf die Kinder
zurück und unsere Kinder brauchen die
Zeit und brauchen die Förderung 13 Uhr
letzte Stunde der 4b Sport mit den
zehnjährigen
erstmal zugeben ehrlich sein prima Max
sabrina nekkov ist mit Leidenschaft
Lehrerin noch für viele andere ist der
Beruf nicht mehr attraktiv durch die
Mehrbelastung die Zusatzarbeit die
ständige Überforderung
das ist eine tickende Zeit Bombe das
System an sich und es wird sich erst
verbessern wenn wir die zeitlichen
Ressourcen die lehrerköpfe haben um uns
hier zu entlasten als dann wird das
Ganze besser werden
[Musik]
das Ticken der Zeitbombe wird auch im
bayerischen marktlaber gehört
wir sind dann der Grund und Mittelschule
verabredet mit Studienrätin Astrids
die 50-Jährige ist aktuell als
Personalrätin freigestellt kümmert sich
um die Sorgen und Nöte ihrer
lehrerkolleginnen
sie bleiben weiter im Krankenstand und
versuchen gesund zu werden und warten
drauf bis der Dienstjahr auf sie zukommt
vielleicht sie einlädt zu einer
amtsärztlichen Überprüfung
Astrid scheels Motto wenn es den Lehrern
gut geht geht es auch den Kindern gut
doch derzeit sieht es schlecht aus
Jammern auf hohem Niveau nein sagt sie
die Folgen der Zusatzbelastungen in
Bayern sein gravierend die Erkrankungen
häufen sich ich kann sogar mit Zahlen
belegen von uns hier in der Oberpfalz
wir haben Statistiken
dienstunfähigkeiten haben sich mehr als
verdoppelt und zwar genau nach
Einführung dieser Maßnahmen zum
Lehrermangel den wir in Bayern 2020
vorgesetzt bekommen haben
[Musik]
doch nicht nur in Bayern deutschlandweit
machen die Zustände an den Schulen
offenbar krank im Schnitt wird jeder
zehnte Lehrer im Jahr dienstunfähig die
Hauptursache sein burnout-erkrankungen
fast jede zweite Lehrkraft sei erschöpft
ein Berufsstand im Ausnahmezustand
die hauptgestellte Frage die im Moment
kommt ist eigentlich wann kann ich
aufhören wie kann ich aufhören und gibt
es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit dass ich
früher aufhören kann
am Abend lädt der Regionalverband
Regensburg des bayerischen Lehrer und
lehrerinnenverband zu einer Versammlung
ein
an der lehrerbasis rumorses viele ärgert
dass die Politik nur zögerlich reagiert
man weiß ja wie viele Kinder auf die
Welt kommen und man weiß auch dass sie
irgendwann in die Schule gehen ist die
Stimmung ist nicht gut wir
retten uns in der
vertretungsplanung von Tag auf den
nächsten Tag ich würde sagen wir stecken
jetzt zur Zeit mit unseren
Bildungssystem wirklich in der tiefen
Krise Simone Fleischmann ist die
Präsidentin des BLV einem der größten
Lehrerverbände bundesweit wenn wir 20
Jahre Lehrer
Mangel hat Kinder da Sitz
en haben wir jeden Tag spüren was die
einzelnen Kinder bräuchten
das aber nicht geben können dann
brauchen wir uns nicht wundern wenn
viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen aufgeben
sie spricht den Anwesenden aus dem
Herzen der hat Schuld an der Misere und
wer sind die Leidtragenden für Simone
Fleischmann liegt die Antwort klar auf
der Hand
die Politiker die in unterschiedlichen
Settings nicht gehört haben dass wir
einen wir einen Lehrermangel
prognostiziert haben man hat immer
versucht alles unter diese Tischdecke zu
kehren und jetzt muss man es teuer
bezahlen wer die Ministerpräsidenten
oder die Kultusministerkonferenz nein
die Schulleiterin vor Ort die Lehrerin
vor Ort das ist die Ansprechpartnerin da
weint das Kind da schimpft der Vater da
gibt's die Klage da wird man krank
Simone Fleischmann spricht von einer
Bildungskatastrophe laut ZDF
Politbarometer sind 91% der Deutschen
der Meinung dass hierzulande für Schule
und Bildung zu wenig getan wird Aussicht
auf Lösungen
das Problem ist auch in der
Bundespolitik angekommen
auf einem von ihr einberufenen
Bildungsgipfel beschreibt die
Bundesministerin den Ernst der Lage
jedes fünfte Kind fast 20%
oder in schreiben die Veranstaltung
sollte Signale setzen
wir sind jetzt an einem entscheidenden
Punkt es ist wichtig dass wir jetzt
gemeinsam starten doch von den 16 für
Bildung zuständigen Kultusministern sind
gerade mal zwei gekommen von anderen
hören wir sie sei nicht rechtzeitig
eingeladen worden
zwei Tage später der eigene Gipfel ist
treffen sich die Kultusminister der
Länder auf ihrer regulären Konferenz der
Lehrermangel spielt auch hier eine Rolle
mal wieder Länder wie Berlin und Sachsen
setzen vor allem auf Quereinsteiger und
Bayern lockt zudem Lehrer auch aus
anderen Bundesländern mit Geld wenn dann
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer aus anderen
Bundesländern zu uns kommen weil wir ein
attraktives Bundesland sind weil wir
vielleicht auch besser zahlen als andere
dann ist das auch gut auch
nordrhein-Westfalen will finanzielle
Anreize zu schaffen deswegen haben wir
in Nordrhein-Westfalen für alle
Lehrkräfte 13 eingeführt das sind
immerhin 900 Millionen Euro bis 2026
alleine das zeigt noch mal dass uns der
Lehrer Beruf sehr sehr wichtig ist
Nordrhein-Westfalen die Länder jagen
sich die wahren Lehrer gegenseitig ab
doch der Mangel bleibt konkrete
Beschlüsse gibt es nicht
die Vorschläge der Experten zu
Mehrarbeit und weniger Teilzeit sollen
die Länder prüfen der Lehrerberuf soll
attraktiver und die Zugänge zum Studium
erleichtert werden wie bleibt offen die
Zeit drängt offenbar nicht bei der
Vorsitzenden der KMK wir werden noch uns
viele Jahre mindestens zehn Jahre darauf
einstellen müssen und irgendwann
Demographie irgendein Jahrgang ist dann
wieder mal so groß dass sich die
Probleme dann
lösen werden also Augen zu und durch ist
das wirklich alles
Bildungspolitik ist Ländersache doch
kriegen die Länder das noch hin drei
Viertel der Deutschen wünschen dass der
Bund sich stärker einmischt
auf die Schnelle sollen es nun
Quereinsteiger richten Menschen die
eigentlich einen anderen Beruf gelernt
haben Sachsen-Anhalt liegt dabei an der
Spitze bei den Neueinstellungen war 2021
fast jeder zweite Lehrer ein
Quereinsteiger in der Not wollen andere
Länder nachziehen und wie klappt das im
Schulalltag
Längenfeld dem Vogtland hier scheint es
jede Menge kluge Köpfe zu geben bei der
PISA-Studie liegt Sachsen auf Platz 1
wir besuchen die Oberschule Gotthold
ephra im Lessing eine Schule mit Idee
auch gegen Lehrermangel
kurz nach 10 Uhr Matheunterricht in der
5a
was wir heute machen ist nochmals selbst
ein Koordinatensystem zeichnen die
x-Achse
zeichnen wir waagerecht immer auf den
Linien bleiben ja ihr arbeitet alle mit
Bleistift und lineare ja nicht
freihändig
20 Kinder arbeiten konzentriert Mario
dobek gibt sich viel Mühe mit den
Elfjährigen
wunderbar das hat toll geklappt
ist kein Lehrer sondern Vertriebsmanager
in einer großen Firma im Ort er hat
selbst zwei Kinder ja leben ist ja
eigentlich jede Woche das Lehrer
ausfallen auch an unseren Schulen wo
meine Kinder hingehen und
dementsprechend war die Entscheidung
relativ einfach zu sorgen wir müssen
noch was tun zwei zwei hast du ja und
deshalb springt der 47-Jährige immer mal
wieder als Ersatzlehrer ein
bisschen angespannt wir sind ins kalte
Wasser geworfen worden haben das bestens
versucht zu lösen und die Kinder geben
meinen aber auch Feedback wir sind
inzwischen vertraut miteinander und so
macht es eigentlich schon Spaß
und so sehen es offenbar auch seine
Schützlinge
er ist ja zwar kein ausgebildeter Lehrer
aber er kann das sehr sehr gut erklären
und er ist auch sehr nett ich finde der
Herr dobek ist nicht so streng wenn wir
da Fragen haben dann sagt er halt nicht
immer der hättet ihr besser aufgepasst
und dann er erklärt uns dann halt noch
einmal und man merkt kaum dass er keine
Richter gar Lehrer ist und was sagt die
Fachlehrerin dazu Kerstin Hein ist froh
um die Entlastung doch auf Dauer sollte
eigentlich ausgebildeter Fachkräfte also
Lehrer mit auch methodischer Ausbildung
an den Schulen arbeiten und die
Seiteneinsteiger haben also da viel
bedarf also da muss viel noch
fortgebildet werden um die Schüler immer
weiter Stange zu halten ist okay
nebenan unterrichtet Schulleiterin Anke
Barth die neuen klässler in Englisch
erstmal sagt Anke Bart mussten sie in
diesem Jahr Unterricht kürzen wegen
Lehrermangel für die Pädagogin ein
unhaltbarer Zustand händeringend suchten
sie an der Schule nach Lösungen setzt
die Schüler Waben mit einer Plakataktion
in der Region um Lehrer vergeblich
das letzte Mittel im Kampf gegen den
Lehrermangel sagt Schulleiterin Anke
Barth sind die fünf Quereinsteiger ohne
die oder
informatikausfallens würde es würde
Englisch ausfallen es würde Mathematik
ausfallen es würde für sich ausfallen
also
keine Frage ohne Quereinsteiger könnte
ich hier kein Unterricht machen
Anke Bart ist bereits wieder am
Organisieren wieder fällt jemand aus
für die 54-Jährige ein ständiges Auf und
Ab zwischen Hoffen und Bangen
das ist sehr bitte das ist wirklich
bitter und das frustriert mich auch weil
das ist eigentlich nicht mein Anspruch
als Schulleiter diesen Mangel zu
verwalten ich möchte ganz gerne
pädagogische Aufgaben machen um einfach
auch die Schule voranzubringen zurück in
die 5a die Mathestunde ist gleich rum
danke schön so gibt's auch keine
Hausaufgaben
auf Dauer sagt du weg sein
Quereinsteiger und Ersatzlehrer jedoch
keine Lösung dass wir über die
Gesellschaft das lösen müssen was
eigentlich das dauert oder die Regierung
lösen muss stimmt ein nachdenklich
das trotz des Chaos an den Schulen
Unterricht noch möglich ist ist häufig
nur den engagierten Lehrern zu verdanken
doch wie lange halten die noch durch
ja Deutschland ist dringend auf gute
Bildung angewiesen andere Ressourcen hat
das Land kaum längst hätten die Weichen
gestellt werden müssen die Politik hat
versäumt genug Anreize zu schaffen um
den Lehrerberuf attraktiver zu machen
[Musik]